no hay Brisa otoñal solo sol y arena ya
que los veraneantes del suroeste de
Francia están tomando el sol en lo que
se supone es su descanso de finales de
octubre en algunas zonas hace más calor
que a finales de junio es increíble
en el resto del departamento de las
landas los cafés y las Terrazas están a
tope
de momento lo aprovecharemos Pero sería
bueno volver a las temperaturas normales
las temperaturas de octubre han subido
drásticamente a causa de un gran sistema
de bajas presiones en el Océano
Atlántico que está trayendo aire cálido
desde España y el norte de África y deja
a las ciudades entre 8 y 9 grados más
calientes de lo habitual un tiempo tan
caluroso Es raro en esta época del año
donde las temperaturas normales de
octubre suelen estar por debajo de los
17 grados esta semana están alcanzando
un máximo de 30 es un poco extraño
vestirse como si estuviéramos al final
del verano cuando en realidad estamos al
final de octubre según los meteorólogos
esta ola de calor tardía Aunque única
puede repetirse en el futuro ya hemos
tenido olas de calor en el pasado que
han durado de 3 a 4 días pero ahora
mismo estamos en el undécimo día y a
finales de mes habremos tenido una ola
de calor de 17 a 18 días
una bola de calor que azota a la Francia
continental durará hasta el final de la